[Musik]
hallo
herzlich willkommen zur sail israels
heute gibt's was leckeres türkisches
manche kennen ja schon einige von euch
mahnte das sind so kleine gefüllte
maultaschen sage jetzt mal wie ravioli
nur wirklich winzig winzig klein heute
machen wir eine abwandlung und zwar geht
es heute diesen mantel
das sind geöffnete kleine teigtaschen
und die sind dann richtig toll aus in
einem blech ich mache jetzt mal zuerst
den teig dafür
für den teig verwende ich 1 200
milliliter warmes wasser einen esslöffel
salz und ich habe ich noch mal gewitzt
zuerst ein bisschen medien die
rührschüssel dann das ei
ich mache es auf den teig einem
handrührgerät könnt natürlich auch
küchenmaschine benutzen
aber ich will ja immer auch zeigen dass
alles ohne geht's oder einfach mit der
hand verkneten wasser salz und bisschen
mehr
jetzt kurz verrühren
dann fühle ich nach und nach das
restliche mehl dazu und wenn ihr möchtet
dann könnt ihr jetzt müssen auch kurkuma
dazu geben
dann bekommt nämlich der teig eine
richtig schöne farbe doch das mache ich
jetzt
[Musik]
laut bis 10,5 zu malen sagt richter
zeitgleich eine richtig schöne farbe
paprikapulver könnte dazu geben dann
wieder schön rot das einfach nach und
nach das mehl dazugeben so dass ein
schöner verteidigen stellt
[Musik]
jetzt wird es jetzt nämlich einfach die
hände zum weiter kneten einfach ein
bisschen mehl darunter gut drauf und
schön verkneten
[Musik]
mit der küchenmaschine hat man zwar die
hände frei aber ich finde so mit der
hand klärte damit war immer so ein
gefühl für den teig und weiß auch wenn
er perfekt ist also der soll jetzt nicht
zu weich sein aber eben auch nicht hart
deswegen kinetischer auf das mehl nach
und nach ein und dem türkischen ich habe
es ja schon mal gesagt da sagt man immer
praxisgebühr also die meisten tester und
ohrläppchen wies ohrläppchen genau wie
es ohrläppchen soll sein aber ein
bisschen fester
also müsste keine ahnung so und kneten
so ein bisschen fester einfach
wieso nudelteig
jetzt lege ich den teig hier einfach in
meine schüsse der gehen ab und lass ihn
ein bisschen ausruhen lässt er sich
gleich etwas leichter ausrollen und in
der zwischenzeit kann ich schon mal die
füllung zu bereiten und auch die früh
ansetzen
ich setze jetzt hier die hühnerbrühe
selber an
ich habe auch immer hähnchenfleisch und
gefrierschrank ich habe ich jetzt
einfach hinter dem flügel genommen ins
kalte wasser gelegt und jetzt habe ich
hier noch andere geschmacksträger hier
zum beispiel petersilien stengel
die schneidet man ja meistens immer weg
ich friere sie dann ein weil ich sie
recht gut für eine frühe nehmen kann
die kommen wir mit rein dann knoblauch
natürlich sellerie stangen habe ich noch
hören ist doch immer so während die
hessen schon zu weich sind zum
wegschmeißen natürlich zu schade
deswegen kommen die immer in der brühe
mit rainer das salz 1 lorbeerblatt
pfefferkörner und noch ein bisschen
muskat und das lasse ich jetzt hier
einfach langsam vor sich hin köcheln
so bekommen die brühe denn richtig
tollen intensiven geschmack und ich kann
in der zwischenzeit schon mal die
füllung vorbereiten
[Musik]
für die füllung verwende ich 30 gramm
butter 2 knoblauchzehen eine zwiebel 200
gramm burth da ist grob 800 gramm
hähnchenbrust etwas salz pfeffer chili
und bohnenkraut die zwiebel und
knoblauchzehen die habe ich jetzt
bereits geschält und die werden jetzt
eingeführt
[Musik]
der über und schmelzen jetzt die butter
hier in einer pfanne und dann gehe ich
da direkt die zwiebel und knoblauch
würfel dazu und kann die so ein bisschen
glasig braten und dann in der
zwischenzeit schon mal das
hähnchenfleisch fein würfeln
also wirklich ganz ganz ganz kleine
das habe ich gerade dazu entschlossen
ich werde jetzt das hähnchenfleisch
dürfe sondern durch den fleischwolf
geben und ich hab hier vorne die grobe
scheibe so wird das ganze nicht zu fein
aber eben auch nicht so kopie wenn man
es schneidet sich hier einfach eingeben
und sprich wolfen und so habe ich halt
auch den vorteil dass es fleisch
wirklich richtig schön gleichmäßig ist
[Musik]
so fertig jetzt nämlich den bulgur den
groben und kann ihn hier heiß waschen
einfach direkt in einem sieb
warten wir noch kurz auf die zwiebeln
und dann können wir gleich die zutaten
alle verrühren
[Musik]
kommen die zwiebel direkt zum fleisch
erfüllung die bleibt jetzt ruhe weil ich
das ganze gleich danach im backofen
garen des wiebel rhein ruhr rhein
gewürze dazu und ich nehme jetzt hier
berg bohnenkraut das habe ich noch
meinen eltern das bringt meine mama
immer aus der türkei mit ihr könnt auch
oregano nehmen oder majoran
ich finde einfach dass beck bohnenkraut
so ganz besonders riecht und beim türken
hier kriegt man es zwar aber oftmals
füllen die nur oregano rein und das ist
schon ein bisschen schade dass pflanzt
sich übrigens auch bald wieder bei uns
in bekannter in den garten und chili
mache ich mal ein bisschen weniger denn
unser chili was wird gerade hier haben
ist sehr sehr schön
wir sitzen dann einfach ein bisschen
nach der tombola und alle anderen die
ethernet so ganz scharf jetzt einfach
schön vermischen abdecken und so seite
stellen am besten kurz im kühlschrank
diesmal dann den teig gerichtet haben
[Musik]
den teig aus und bei monday ist es
normalerweise so dass man ein opfer
nimmt also diesen langen ausfall starb
die sind aus holz und dann rollt man
eben hier einfach die nudel platte aus
und schneidet dann eben in quadrate oder
rechtecke ich mache ganz gern immer mit
einer nudelmaschine weil ich muss ja
sowieso rechtecke schneiden und dann ist
es einfacher ich habe als
ausgangsprodukt eben auch eine
rechteckige platte
ihr könnt jetzt entweder den teig eben
auch mit der hand aus folgen als kreis-
oder nudeln maschine oder zum beispiel
eine mit handkurbel das ist eigentlich
auch noch ganz praktisch ich nehme jetzt
im teig und dann will ich ihn so ein
bisschen bisschen drücken für die
nudelmaschine vorbereiten die hälfte vom
teig möglich solange noch weg dass er
nicht austrocknet
[Musik]
farbe ist richtig richtig schön geworden
jetzt gerne nochmal falken dann bekomme
ich nämlich auch eine schöne richtige
platte nehmen
[Musik]
ein bisschen feucht deswegen gebe ich
jetzt einfach nur drauf dann arbeitet
sich dann das meliá sowieso in den teig
rein und dann klappt's dann guckt jetzt
habe ich hier rechts und links richtig
schöne gerade kam
[Musik]
wenn jetzt langsam das dünne ausrollen
und da zeigt ist auch wie eine art
nudelteig nur mit weniger als dass er
nur 1 1 drin und etwas mehr wasser
[Musik]
jetzt auch nur bis stufe 4
und jetzt rechtecke zuschneiden und ich
mache das jetzt ein bisschen blöd weil
es echt zu vereinfacht geht und vor
allem richtig gleichmäßig wird
[Musik]
die übrigen teig nehme ich jetzt hier
einfach weg
mit zimmer drei viertel teelöffel von
der erfüllung nehmen und die teigtaschen
damit gefüllt dann etwas länglich formen
und hier oben die ecken so
zusammendrücken wieso kleine schiffchen
falls die thailänder nicht halten könnte
einfach ein bisschen wasser in die ecken
der stadt zusammen
[Musik]
und die habe ich jetzt das blech ich
nehm i mei blech und habe hier butter
drin und drei habt einfach den vorteil
ihr könnt hier auf dem herd stellen kurz
den herd an machen und die butter darin
schmelzen lassen und dann die ganze form
aus butter
[Musik]
dann liegt es ja einfach direkt ins
blech ins gefettete einfach rings herum
und dann entsteht dann eine richtig
schöne optik
[Musik]
reduziert ist große blech gefüllt und
das ist auch echt schon randvoll
das nicht schon mal mache ich das so
davor mich sie zu essen setzte danach
ins blech dann passen nämlich auch mehr
rein
ich nehme jetzt einfach die übrigen die
ich habe hier und legt sie in ein
kleines immer jedes blech was ich auch
ganz hübsch wind wenn ihr so kleine
förmchen habt dann könnt ihr nämlich
eine portion für eine person machen
richtig schön jedenfalls hat die
füllungen genau erreicht und dabei auch
alles ist perfekt ausgegangen ich habe
einfach immer drei viertel teelöffel von
der füllung genommen also nicht so wenig
nehmen und schön formen und dann passt
alles perfekt jetzt kommen die man sie
in den vorgeheizten backofen und da
werden sie erst einmal knusprig gebacken
und dann habe ich die butter und dann
wird es eine richtig schöne butter koste
unten und später kommt dann erst die
hühnerbrühe drauf damit jemand auch
weich werden und wir uns die zähne
ausbeißen
[Musik]
schön sehen sie aus guckt mal richtig
schön
und jetzt kommt hier die brühe drauf
einfach mit einem schöpflöffel übergeben
so schön die mahnte damit bedeckt
ich habe so eine kleine stadt lagen der
große teil liegt irgendwo ich weiß ich
mache die brühe am besten auch direkt
abgeschmeckt wunder wenn sie nämlich zu
wenig sein sagt können wir jetzt noch an
der stelle ist alles zu finden wird so
dass ungefähr noch mal so ein halber
zentimeter brühe über den man darüber
steht das wirklich alles schön mit der
früher bedeckt sind
so kommen sie jetzt noch mal in den ofen
und werden fertig gegart und ich kann in
der zwischenzeit schon mal den joghurt
zusammengehören und auch die paprika
soße
die man sie sind jetzt fertig und jetzt
kommt noch die soße und zwar habe ich
jetzt hier ein bisschen butter
geschmolzen
da kommt jetzt tomatenmark und paprika
mark dazu dass paprika mag das ist immer
schon gesalzen das gibt es übrigens
neben türkischen laden und das ist hier
einfach ein bisschen mit anbraten
das ist eigentlich immer so die basis
von allen türkischen gerichten mutter
und paprika und tomatenmark die zwiebel
knoblauch natürlich ich habe jetzt hier
noch die kleine portionen die kann ich
nämlich leichter morath probieren ich
hab mir einfach dass er mal kurz auf den
herd gestellt so kann man es nämlich
noch mal schön warm machen oder warm
halten
jetzt kann ich noch schnell die joghurt
soße anrühren
ich habe jetzt in joghurt dann nehme ich
immer gerne wären zehnprozentigen mit
dem dave die stadt cremig da ein
bisschen winzerei dann natürlich salz
und ein bisschen knapper so murat freut
sich schon
ja das ist strasser stillende ecke
gabriele comstor kurz genau und zwar
dann hier ist der italiener zwar gibt's
knoblauch dann gehe jetzt mal ganz
ehrlich er begrüßte die türkisch spiel
kannst hier und da silvas was sagt das
natürlich ist daher schon auf ahmet öner
und zum schluss inzwischen ist ja alles
aufgezählt was nicht aus der türkei
ausgesprochen gut aus perfekt
ausgesprochen aber auch die türkische
küche ist will ich was ging alles und es
ist kein spaß die türkische küche ist
einer der abwechslungsreichsten der welt
es ist wirklich so nein es ist idiotisch
zwar auch cool aber wirklich die
türkisch kirche hat damit zum
geografisch gelegen welt türkei ist ein
vielvölkerstaat
und da gibt es alles möglich alle
möglichen einflüsse und deswegen ist die
tüv studie wirklich einer der
einflussreichsten der welt steht
übrigens auch als geschichte in einem
typischen kopf genau ob sie ein kleines
kochbuch bin jetzt nicht guckt euch mal
das an richtig gegen das hier ist die
große portion da sieht man auch ganz gut
aber auch schön gemüsebrühe dran
ich glaube dass ich jetzt vielleicht
einen tick zu wenig gemüse wurden hat
aber dann ist ein bisschen komisch schon
wie cool es aussieht an jede also wo ist
bei karriere auf der leider nicht
probieren ich muss nämlich noch fotos
schießen
okay kein problem schluss mit ihr ein
bisschen mitmachen autostopperin zeit
musst du mal gehört
das ist nicht gerade habe ich
vorgestellt verpasst seinem einfachen
dann jene daniele ist gründer von
webnews kennen wahrscheinlich schon kann
man eigentlich mit ihr gemacht
jetzt auch neuigkeit genau das kurze
schnelle platzierung rausgehauen aber
ist noch 1 daniel ist die sind noch ein
bisschen weiter da war mein gemüse
früher darüber
da sollten wir auf jeden fall darauf
achten falls das rezept nach machen
wollt findet ihr es auch zweli suisse
blockte er ihr könnt natürlich auch
weiter füllung variieren ich habe jetzt
hähnchenfleisch und bulgur drin im
hamburger ihr könnt natürlich auch eine
hackfleisch bildung machen eine
vegetarische kartoffel füllung der
spinat ricotta füllung so ein bisschen
italienisch alles was er möchte und wenn
ihr das rezept nach macht dann verlinkt
mich auf jeden fall auf euren fotos dann
können wir gerne mal reinschauen
also viel spaß beim nachmachen guten
appetit sagt man schließe mich hier
gerade aber gut auf was heißt guten
appetit auf italienisch unterricht aber
natürlich marschiert aufs jahr genau und
jung sein
[Musik]